AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
AMAZON WISH LIST: VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: I KNOW THAT SPECIAL
ZAZZ YOU FEEL IN THE AIR IS THAT
YOU'RE ALL AWARE
IT'S VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S BIRTHDAY TODAY.
>> TODAY?
Chris: YES, TODAY.
>> HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
Chris: YES, HERE'S RUSSIA'S
CUDDLEIEST DESPOT RIGHT HERE
BEFORE HE STRANGLED THE PRIME
MINISTER OF AUSTRALIA.
>> WHAT DO YOU GET FOR THE
HOMOPHOBIC VODKA-FILLED MELON
MAN WHO HAS IT ALL?
COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO GIVE ME SOME OF THE
ITEMS ON PUTIN'S AMAZON WISH
LIST IN 60 SECONDS AND BEGIN.
>> SYRIA.
>> CROTCHLESS WRESTLING
SINGLETS. YES, POINTS.
>> A REAL DOLL OF ANGELA MIRCLE.
>> "ENTOURAGE" BOXSET.
>> A REAL GAYDAR.
>> A WEDDING DRESS FOR HIS
HORSE.
>> HOT WHEELS.
>> ELI.
>> A SADDLE FOR HIS BEAR.
Chris: POINTS.
YES.
I'M TIRED OF RIDING BAREBACK.
IT WORKS TWO WAYS.
>> OH.
>> TWO PUNS FOR THE PRICE OF ONE
PUN.